what's up guys
bang bang we're in the studio but
nobody's here
we're literally by ourselves situation i
don't even know how to use the
uh cameras yet so uh we're just gonna do
it right here on this nice computer that
we have
that looks so amazing what's up it looks
great but you keep
moving the desk which therefore moves
the computer and shakes us
don't forget that block five now sponsor
of lunch money that means you can go to
blackfire.com
and you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy an interest bearing account
you can sign up for the waitlist for the
bitcoin rewards credit card it's coming
soon i got an update recently the
bitcoin rewards credit card is coming
very very soon make sure you are on the
waitlist go to blockfit.compomp
and sign up for the waitlist for the
bitcoin rewards credit card
swipe a regular credit card you'll get
bitcoin back instead of
cash or airline miles block fire.com
what's up
hi guys okay elon musk was on snl
and we stayed up until 1am to watch it
did you like it yeah it was fine did you
think that it humanized them
i did think it humanized them and i said
leave it to snl to humanize musk
because he was awkward but he he was
like reading the teleprompter but he was
also self-aware so it made it funny
he was like hey guys i think he was
excited to do
this like i literally think he had fun
doing it and that's the most important
part because it comes through as he was
doing it
also his mom was awesome did you know
she used to be a model
may may musk was a model
that that name may have uh if you were a
kid might get you a little bit of
trouble but
you know wait why may musk like
may you have some musk who knows
okay not funny ask funny him not funny
all right all right all right moving on
to something
less funny jobs report was
a april's expected hiring boom goes
bust um it was a huge letdown
with non-farm payrolls increasing by a
much less than expected
266 thousand dollars dow jones had
estimated
uh 1 million new jobs and an
unemployment rate of 5.8 percent
instead the unemployment rate rose to
6.1 percent
and only 266 000 jobs were
added i tweeted this last week if
they're off by 75
in the payroll numbers
how far off are they on inflation or any
other metric that they give us
75 percent how do they
just happen absurd now
anthony scaramucci was on cnbc today and
he actually had a very very
interesting point which he said listen
there's a lot of seasonal control
in these numbers he even dropped a big
sat word he said
numerology which is uh number
orology and the whole idea is
maybe we shouldn't actually incorporate
some of the seasonality into it
because if you have more digital workers
than not there is no seasons in the
digital world
right so it used to be like the farm
payroll
certain places in the country can uh
allow for
farming certain places can't because of
weather so you try to control for that
to be able to compare month to month to
month
well they're off by 75 so something's
broke whether it's their counting
their methodology something is wrong can
i just say that numerology is astrology
with numbers so i don't know what you're
talking about
wow i'm just saying listen his name's
anthony he went on cnbc he dropped the
word i liked the word i thought was a
great word so i said hey if it's good
enough for him then it's good enough for
me neurology is how to calculate life
path and destiny it's the belief
it's not numerology
put a b in there number you know like
the number
oh
it's the belief in the divine or the
mystical relationship between a number
and one or more coinciding events
yeah well that's what they're doing
they're just making up stuff
all right goldman sachs internal memo
unveils a new cryptocurrency trading
team wow there's two there's a newly
created cryptocurrency desk
and it had successfully traded two kinds
of bitcoin linked derivatives
according to an internal goldman sachs
memo
uh they've done this before didn't go
very far
i hope that they do it we will see
though
everybody's gonna have to be coming in
here bitcoin is inevitable
cryptocurrencies are inevitable
see ya on the playing field gs
club house is finally launching its
android app for a long time you could
only access clubhouse even if you were
invited
on the iphone and it has now launched
its beta
android app what do we think about our
android friends
android friends there it was like 85
market share by android over
ios so this makes a lot of sense very
concerning for clubhouse
uh in terms of monthly downloads have
been decreasing pretty rapidly
really yes a lot um i think they're not
even getting a million downloads per
month right now um
my guess though is i would not count it
out i would not bet against them
uh whenever you get a team that has had
success like this they've got a lot of
capital
uh usually what happens is they just got
to figure it out right like hey do we
have product market fit probably okay
how do we actually get growth going okay
let's add another platform let's go to a
new geography should we do something
around language right just all these
little growth things that you can do
to really make sure that the product
continues to grow but can i tell you my
problem with clubhouse like i feel like
i don't know
how's got a problem with you no i don't
uh i downloaded it and i was super
excited about it i like in the beginning
i was logging on listening to
conversations or whatever
and then i kind of stopped because it
was an incredibly huge time suck
and i know the same happened to you so
how do they solve that problem
well people are just going to come and
use it as they see fit
like i still will go on there but i'm
not going to go spend all my time on
there
so i think it's just you know people
will figure out how they want to use it
which is
the beauty of a platform like this right
okay so there is a company that is
offering
you 1500 for taking a nap
every day for 30 days
it's called the company is called each
night and it offers mattress reviews and
sleep guides and tips
and it's hiring a team of nap reviewers
to test a few theories behind the pros
and cons of napping
so they if this company will pay you 15
i do it for free
i do it for free every day who they're
gonna pay me fifteen hundred dollars
there's a catch here they ain't just
paying you to sleep there's a cat i
don't know what the catch is but there's
a catch for sure and i ain't gonna
i'm not signing up for no catches wait
why because i just know there's a catch
they ain't just giving you 1500 bucks to
take a nap
i want you to know they want you to give
them feedback or information
or whatever i got time for all of that
will be trying to trick me with the nap
and then get the information
give some feedback for 1500 for a nap i
would no
i'd give up pay me what i'm worth
anthony
tell them about your when you woke up in
the middle or you didn't wake up you
were sleep talking
when so he was sleep talking in the
middle of the night
and and i woke up because he he'd be
loud
and he goes way to go
champ i was like what are you dreaming
about
like a look at it i've never heard you
use those words in real life i don't
know either
dream life obviously the champ did
something so i was proud let's go
okay it's ask lunch money time hashtag
ask
lm in the comments below today's
question comes from brent kt
welcome back do i buy an eight sleep or
buy bitcoin or is this like asking you
to choose between your kids
both of them are good for your health
bitcoin is good for your mental health
eight sleep is good for your mental and
physical health i don't choose between
the two
but uh i got a little bit of bitcoin i
got a little bit of eight sleep but the
problem is you can buy a little bit of
bitcoin but you can't buy a little bit
of eight sleep yes you can you can buy
either the mattress and the pad
or you can just buy the pad see a little
bit you don't have to get the whole
thing and get the little pad
she was not expecting me to come with
that fire way to go
yeah way to go champ all right guys
that's it see you later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest-bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoying in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends